today we will measure the speed of light
with a bar of chocolate a microwave oven
a ruler and a little bit of math to
measure the speed of light what we do is
we put a solid bar of chocolate into the
microwave but we don't rotate it we keep
it steady
still so that those troughs and Peaks
can be seen once we know the distance
between the troughs and the peaks we can
multiply that by the frequency of the
microwave 2,450 megahertz
multiply it by 2 because we want the
wave length between each peak not the
peak in the trough and that way you get
the speed of light
least in theory you take your ordinary
bar of chocolate open your ordinary
microwave you put your ordinary bar of
chocolate in there we're going to do 20
seconds the chocolate being heated but
it's not moving
we open again and you can now see small
bubbles that indicate the hot spots in
the chocolate if you measure these the
distance between these hot spots is
about 6 centimeters like I said you
multiply that by 2 6 times 2 to 12 and
you multiply that by the megahertz of
the microwave
2,450 megahertz which translates to
about 2.5 billion cycles a second you
multiply that together you get twenty
nine point four billion centimeters per
second which is roughly the speed of
light is within 2% so we've proven speed
of light bar of chocolate and Wired's
incomparable but flawed microwave
you